well here in the desert our cars really
hit up a lot quicker than other parts of
the country yeah and a new bill is being
discussed in the legislature that could
give you the power to save a child or a
pet in distress Victoria Saha shows us
how to do it safely if it passes
[Music]
Nevada is no stranger to hot summers but
the desert heat could be
life-threatening especially if you're
stuck in a car where it's even hotter
that would mean everything
probably literally life or death
according to kidsandcars.org an average
of 38 children across the country die of
heat stroke every year after being left
in a car Glenn Leonard says he would
jump into action to save anyone stuck in
a hot car I would just probably live
with the uh if they would choose to
litigate and sue me for a break you know
breaking a window with a new bill being
discussed in the Nevada legislator
would protect anyone who broke a window
because they found a child or a pet in a
car under extreme weather conditions
last summer Metro Police saved two dogs
after they were left in a hot car but
before you jump in to break a car window
you have to do it safely so no one
inside gets hurt Leonard owns a salvage
yard and gave us some tips if you have a
hammer or a tire iron I would step back
out of the way
and just give it a nice hard hit
you may have a hammer in your car but
you might want to buy a tactical pen
they're not that expensive but very
effective effect if you use them
properly you always want to aim for the
corner of the window
and now that you have an opening this is
where you can use a hammer to break the
whole window down
experts say you have to break the window
that's furthest away from the child that
way they aren't hit with glass
so today's hearing was just the first
part of this bill there were many people
present including the Humane Society and
a representative from Metro there was no
opposition with this bill so you can
only break a window if the car is locked
and after you break it you have to stay
with the child or the pet until police
arrive